[Applause]
shining it is lovely to see you look at
the effect you're having on London so
this show is based on some of your
experiences with an 18 year old is this
premium back memories you know every
time I see the show and I see these guys
I've tried to explain to them I did this
in my car like a strip mall and
for about 20 women at a night like I
mean it was completely different it's
not even close to being the same town I
was just a guy that just like to dance
and that was that there and such a
differently and I just when I say every
single one
like the town pool in London
we had an embarrassment of riches now is
it true that this show is so raunchy
that it has to have a safe word
I don't know that wrong but I think we
all should have a safe word at all times
and just in life I don't know if it's
true granted but we go there we try to
push the line and because when you feel
safe you feel liberated
absolutely and what do you hope people
are gonna get out of this and they come
to watch it do you think it's gonna be a
mainly female audience I don't know I
mean we're it's open to everybody but I
mean we made it for women that was the
intention I made it I found as many of
the most
woman like pro shop
it's a really a really female team is
mad it's off I mean there's many Rachel
Alison Teresa I mean when I say like I
just I was like we can't be a bunch of
men
that's what the first two movies were
and they're weird feather fish type
films they're a bunch of guys about
we just didn't want to do that for the
third movie especially in this me too
you know post me to era it's it's a
complicated time and like it's a good
time it's a good time but it's it's
complicated we're just trying to further
this conversation because there is no
there's no right answers it's just like
more exploration and communication